elden ring spoilers are already
surfacing cyberpunk 2077 won't be
getting a metro and more
elden ring spoilers are leaking ahead of
the game's release as some fans have
gotten hands on their copies early while
eldon ring has a planned launch of
february 25th some players have managed
to get their copies just over a week
early and are streaming the game on
twitch not only that but the game's
intro cinematic has been released early
as well alongside some screen grabs and
gameplay features publisher bandai namco
is doing what it can to take down the
leaks but do be careful when looking
things up about el dinnering online if
you want to go in as spoiler free as
possible now might be the time to avoid
social media altogether on the other
hand if you're looking to learn more
about the game gamespot recently had
some hands-on time with it where we
covered 13 things we think you should
know about eldon ring
now that players have had some time with
cyberpunk 2077's 1.5 patch they're
starting to discover all types of new
secrets under the hood however a
screenshot shared on reddit of an
existing asset had the metro discussion
circulating again
even with the existence of fast travel
some players have still been clamoring
for a metro within night city while it
might not have become an optimal way to
travel many want it for the immersion of
living in a bustling city or the
opportunity to see the city from the
rail lines cyberpunk 2077's global
community director was quick to clarify
on twitter that there will definitely
not be a metro added to the game and the
screenshot that was circulating was
completely unrelated if you'd like to
take matters into your own hands then
you should keep an eye on the cyberpunk
2077 metro system mod by keanu wheeze
this mod is not currently compatible
with patch 1.5 but it features 19
working stations and full integration
with the game's ui and controls so it
might be worth checking out if and when
it's updated how do you feel about an
official metro never coming to night
city let me know in the comments
a new patch for dying light 2 has gone
live on pc and between a few tweaks to
the zombie apocalypse sandbox one of the
game's more annoying bugs has been fixed
as pc players discovered loading a fresh
save of 9 light 2 occasionally locked
them into a death loop
not that one where they'd constantly die
over and over dying during a quest
within a restricted area would result in
them being respawned in a different area
and facing a time limit that would not
allow them to get back to the previous
mission area on time that issue has been
fixed alongside a few others a
playstation and xbox version of this
patch will also be going live soon
according to teclan
in other dying light 2 news the game's
first free dlc is now available if you
sided with the game's militaristic
peacekeepers you can grab the authority
pack that includes some neat clothing
and armor on february 18th the
two-handed authority hammer will be made
available
if you've already snagged the dying
light 2 dlc what do you think of it so
far let me know in the comments and of
course leave a like subscribe and come
back tomorrow for another episode of
gamespot news see you later
[Music]
you